guys billy and i both have an expressvpn
account it doesn't matter what mode you
use or how many times you clear your
browsing history
all isps in the us can legally sell your
information to ad companies
but expressvpn is an app that re-roots
your internet connection through their
secure servers
so they can't do that so protect your
online activity today with the vpn rated
number one by cnet
and wired visit my exclusive link
expressvpn.com
onion and you can get an extra three
months free on a one-year package
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
onion expressvpn.com
onion to learn more
harmonize with me and hold me tightly
all through the night
you're shining bright i'm your host the
baby you're my pearl
[Music]
hello dominic hello william isn't it
nice to be back
is that a new jumper it is a new jumper
that
i think is a jumper
that we you and i also have similar
hoodies of and so does your wife
does your son as well yeah i love this
stuff
it's like a venice west side vibe but i
tell you what
they they're not sponsoring us i don't
know my wife just bought me as a gift
lovely and it's called aviator nation
yeah it's and it's so comfortable
oh it's really comfy it's got that kind
of you just got out of the ocean after a
surf the sun's going down maybe you buy
a campfire
she probably saw that in a shot and
thought my husband's cuddly
yeah but if i want to ramp up his
cuddliness yeah i'm going to get him on
him you look fantastic
thank you very much dominic and who's
that you've got on your t-shirt there oh
it looks like it's the joker but it's
also the guy from ronald mcdonald's
one of my favorite t-shirts is from
thailand as i'm sure you know because
we've been to thailand thailand makes
some of the greatest t-shirts out there
and this is one of the t-shirts on khao
san road it is
heath ledger as the joker uh
dressed as ronald mcdonald i remember
very sad very sad when heath led you
died but
my mom did make me giggle when she
called me up the following morning and
said
i'm so sorry to hear about that lovely
actor who passed away
and i said yeah it was a shame she said
i know you were a big fan of keith
i didn't correct my mum because i just
thought her heart's in the right place
she doesn't need to know that he's not
called keith and she'll get a lot of
stuff like that wrong will she
your mother she does have a few of those
she does
um i think it's fun for people to know
that we're not just doing this for a
living
i'm coming down to your house on a
sunday i'll probably bring some potato
crisps with me if you don't mind i'm
thinking lovely two flavors
oh what what cane i think one is gonna
be a crinkle cut
salt and vinegar kettle chip fantastic
now the other one i'm thinking
something is a tonic to that maybe a
spice maybe a vinegar
do you know what i mean i'm not sure yet
i'm still trying to work it out now tell
me this then
go on if you would like to impress my
wife in any way i always want to
she did say that she had a want
for a packet of skips you can't get
skips in the united states if you could
find a packet of skips
here in los angeles that's a great
before you come down on sunday she would
love that quite a bizarre
crisp the the shape of a flower petal
a classic flower petal but with like
bubbly kind of a wafer type vibe to them
so that when you put them on your tongue
they can sometimes almost disappear into
dissolve
and what would you say the flavor is a
prony i would call that a prawn cocktail
wow there's no chance i'm getting skips
for your wife you shouldn't be so you
know
defeatist yes there's a there's an a
british
shop in santa monica but they don't have
them
i'll tell you what they do have skips
all right well maybe up maybe i'll go
via the skip shot
um and also i'll bring a lovely bottle
of wine and we can just
do i hear my uh opening in a bottle of
wine impression well hold on
because this is a this is an audio
medium this will be brilliant audio guys
so just imagine billy and i are opening
a
that was great here's the thing john
people have been rating and it's lovely
isn't it it's nice to hear it's been
great but most of the ones that i've uh
been getting has been like
can you hike off no they haven't it's
been a lot of like
do a show on your own no they haven't
seen the irish
guy have you said that
but i tell you one thing they have been
asking why
the friendship onion why is it called
the friendship onions
a good question that's a great question
and one that we can answer
and we can do it by looking back
into the past through the veil of time
we shall peel back that veil we
we did almost kind of like a a test
podcast back in the day didn't we
yeah excuse me we were doing a podcast
together
and someone else's podcast yes our
friend michael rosenbaum who has a
podcast called
inside of you if you want to check it
out love you you should it's lovely and
we had said to michael since you're all
set up here
yeah could we rent out your space for
the next hour
for free for free do a test
and see how it goes and he said guys we
i would
be honored if you would do that so we
did it
and we have a little piece of audio to
play you guys where billy and i
in real time figured out the title of
the show
shall we play it no dom yeah let's play
it you ready john let's do it
hello i'm dominic monahan and i'm billy
boyd we are here
in a podcast studio doing a podcast
about
lots of stuff but we met during the
filming
of the trilogy the lord of the rings
remember that
so we have a lot of stories about the
lord of the rings
i for me it feels like this is a podcast
about two friends who met during lord of
the rings talking about their life
with a backdrop of the lord of the rings
there at all times in case one of us
gets really boring
you can say well let's do a lord of the
rings story i think you've summed it up
well there
and also we never knew each other
before lord of the rings i mean we have
the rehearsals of course
and we have the filming so we know each
other before lauder rings was in the
cinemas
but we don't know each other without a
lot of the rings being in our lives
so maybe whilst exploring this podcast
and lord of the rings law and our whole
adventure doing there we might begin to
unpeel
the friendship by learning more about
each other when we didn't know each
other
a friendship onion welcome to the
friendship onion
wonders it's poetry
well there you go there it is right
there in
real time it just happened like that i
think
with me saying on peel you immediately
thought
oh i'll have to go home and unpeel an
onion later so then you just said onion
it's like pavlovian that just came out
right but there was also
there was a scent of onion in the air i
don't know what you'd been eating
so i think that had an invaded my mind
as well
i do like an onion you do i tell you
what i had last night which i think is
one of the most simple but decadent
meals that you can have go i had
cheese on toast a little bit of onion
can i talk you through it i wouldn't
call it decadent
it's very decadent for me because i
don't tend to eat cheese
right and i don't tend to eat butter too
much right
all black olive sourdough right
lovely toasted out of the toaster
butter then mature english oh sorry
sorry
marmite spread thinly
on the buttered bread right and then
wafer thin slices of mature english
cheddar
and then some slices of white onion
my god that is a flavor sensation i find
it quite decadent
i think that sounds lovely it was it was
absolutely fantastic i love that someone
said who thought a toast
who looked at bread and said let's cook
that again
that's brilliant isn't it it is is
fantastic toast
man i lived on marmite on toast
when i was uh a student i still like it
a lot now that's another one that we
should do on billion dollar meet the
world because
marmite is an interesting thing right
it's a strange flavor for me strange
it's got that kind of love it or hate it
thing yeah
are you in the kind of not too keen camp
i mean
if i had to say just now i'm in neither
camp okay
i'm in the river between the camps maybe
something for us to talk about
on a billion dollar world oh another
thing i want to talk to you about right
remember i've got this on my phone do
you remember a couple of podcasts ago we
were talking about
petrol and gas
yeah and you had said to me well i think
it's called gas because of
gasoline yeah it's short for gasoline
gasoline and i said yeah i think you're
right
i looked up the ecology of this gasoline
is an english world that
word that donates fuel for automobiles
the term is thought to have been
influenced by the trademark
gasoline or gasoline
named after the surname of a british
publisher and coffee merchant
and social campaigner john castle so he
took his word castle and turned it to
castleene
on november 22nd uh 27th 1862
castle placed an advertisement in the
times of london the patent
gasoline oil safe economical brilliant
possesses all the
requisites which have so long been
desired
as a means of powerful artificial light
but this is where it gets interesting
wait do you hear this
this is the earliest occurrence of the
word to have been found
castle discovered that a shopkeeper in
dublin
named samuel boyd
boyd was selling counterfeit
gasoline and wrote him to stop boyd did
not reply
and changed every c into a g
thus coining the word gasoline
so it's a bastardization of the word
gasoline which is a trademark
of just saying well i'm going to take
this oil and give it the name of my
family
interesting right blah blah blah blah
petroleum
the word petroleum originally used to
refer to the various types of minerals
and oils and literally means
rock oil patrolling trollium
that great so one of your distant
cousins my great great great
great grandfather was it was in ireland
was he
he was irish and he was a little
nefarious because he took someone's
invention
and he said well i'm going to call it
i'm going to sell it illegally
castle came along and said you can't do
that and he said well i'll just change
it to castle instead
it became gasoline amazing what you
learned
he brought it to the new land in the
americas
the internet has a lot to be ashamed of
but wikipedia is fantastic
most of it's not true yeah a lot of it
is just made up by
like people who want to talk about it
right but isn't it great
like my son has never lived in a world
where you had to kind of learn something
or have a book because it's all there
it's in your phone
library yeah i remember as a kid one of
my history uh
homeworks was present
an essay about anything a historical
document
so i went with my dad to the library and
i wasn't really sure where to begin
and my dad said why don't you start
looking at you know egyptian
egyptology and things like that and i
stumbled upon the rosetta stone which
was one of the foremost
tablets to solve hieroglyphics yeah and
did an essay about that
now nowadays your son would be able to
obviously type in
rosetta stone in his house in your house
do it all then but there's something to
be said for going to a library and
remember those really long yeah kind of
book like bookcases that you had to look
through
in because if he clicks on the wrong
thing he'd just end up learning german
or something
this podcast is sponsored by better help
is there something
interfering with your happiness or
preventing you from achieving your goals
like maybe a new job that you would like
yeah that can you know provide a little
bit of stress in your life better help
will assess your needs and match you
with your own
licensed professional therapist and a
great thing you can start communicating
with them in under 48 hours
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it is professional counselling
done securely online
and they've got a broad range of
expertise which might not be
locally available in many areas yeah in
fact the service is
available worldwide for everyone you
just log into your account anytime
and you can send a message to your
counselor better help once you start
living a happier life today so visit
betterhelp.com
forward slash onion that's better
h-e-l-p and join over a million people
who have taken charge of their mental
health with the help
of an experienced professional in fact
so many people have been using better
help
that they are now recruiting additional
counselors in all 50 states special
offer for the friendship on your
listeners get 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
forward slash onion
guys if you're worried about losing your
hair billy and i might have a solution
for you
and i bet there's quite a few men out
there who are because there's
50 million men in the u.s who suffer
from male pattern boldness
yeah two out of three men will
experience some sort of
hair loss by the time they're 35. so
here's a company it's called
keeps k-e-e-p-s they offer a simple
stress-free way to keep your hair yeah
easier access to hair loss treatment
they have a prescription medication that
is delivered directly to your home and
they have an
online doctor that you can consult with
see that's a great thing you don't need
to go to the doctor's office and
wait for all that it's a virtual doctor
you do it online and the medications are
delivered straight to your door not only
that but it's low cost
treatments start at just 10 a month and
keeps offers generic
versions and if you're a little nervous
about getting it delivered in the mail
don't worry because they use discreet
packaging and they have proven results
well keep says more five-star reviews
than any of its competitors so if you're
ready to take action and prevent hair
loss go to keeps.com that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash onion to get your first
month of treatment
for free that's keeps.com onion
and you'll get your first month free
keeps
dot com slash onion oh
emails and real mails fastest tigers
slow
snail billy we've had some great
questions again
from uh from listeners if you want to
send us any
questions the friendship onion at
castmedia.com that's cast with a k
with a kicking cake with a kicking k um
also the quiz if you guys want to get
involved in a quiz
let us know now keep in mind of course
if you want it to be a lord of the rings
quiz it can be a lord of ends quiz but
you might want to quiz
billy on his band bee cake
or on scotland you might want to quiz me
on insects
you might want to quiz billy and i on
lord of the rings or
star wars or something it doesn't have
to be lord of the rings of course if you
want it to be lord rings
it can because i quite enjoy when we get
people on and we do the lord of rings
quiz
so and now that we've sorted it now that
john
has you know basically been put in his
place yeah yeah and he did do quite well
he did very well to be honest he did
incredible but
yeah so the the lord of rings quiz but
that could open up to be a quiz about
movies yeah i love the lord of the rings
thing too it's fantastic and if you want
to ask us questions about lord rings or
you want us to ask you questions about
lord rings of course
let us know but maybe you want to quiz
us if you're on mastermind
then you had to pick a specialized
subject but you couldn't pick yourself
because i think people always go well
i'd just answer questions about me yeah
what would be a specialized subject well
that's a good one is that isn't it
uh pop music from the 1980s
84 to 89. oh wow how about you
i would do
i would do that's got to be ants doesn't
it
i mean ants would be a good one but ants
there are so many different species of
ant and it's such
a an extensive amount to know about so
i'm trying to yeah
i'm trying to get it inside something
yeah because you
because you would think beetles do no i
don't mean beetles the ones that me
i mean the ones that hey yeah and then
yeah those ones but if you do the
question
if you do mastermind on the beatles
they're gonna go
deep oh they're gonna do a deep dive so
sorry about that dog no no it's all
right i would probably
do because you're right the beatles they
would they would have to go so deep for
that
i'd probably do spinal tap the movie
i think i probably know
enough stuff to do mastermind with that
can you do mastermind
on one movie is that loud yeah because
i've seen people do
mastermind on one tv show well here's
the kind of thing that they would ask
you though
are you ready for this oh go on is this
a spinal question yeah but this is the
stuff that they would ask you though
who was the director of photography
on spinal tap because that's the
questions you're going to get
you know who was the lead guitarist
right but do you know the answer to this
of course not well then that's not a
legitimate question
you have to know the answer to ask it
well who is the lead guitarist
of spinal tap nigel toughnell well done
thank you
anyway you you guys know how to get in
touch get in touch with us
also you know billy and don meet the
world we want to go as far around the
world
as possible anyway we've got a question
here first question from
elena elena
is that right i would go just with elena
okay there's an
eye in there that threw me off right
elena goal oh the goal wasp that's a
very interesting insert but we weren't
good
from st paul in minnesota united states
who says if you could learn a new
subject or skill from the world's
top expert in that particular field what
subject or skill would that be well
i think i know mine do you know yours
yeah i'd like to do a
two-week intensive and i don't know who
with
on quantum physics and the string theory
because i've read a lot of books and i
don't know if i know
any more about it it's complicated isn't
it it's
very complicated but oh it's good stuff
i love it
as we get down smaller to the small
small stuff more when i say small i
don't mean like
rabbits and mice no you're going smaller
sugar
smaller i mean the bits inside the sugar
that make up the sugar particles the
molecules smaller the stuff the
smaller the quantum the protons smaller
smaller than a pronto pro
like the the protons little sister yes
the
the the little guy that hangs like the
joe pesci
if let's say robert de niro is a proton
yeah
joe pesci george joe pesci's kid
john percy's ken shoe
lace on your pistols
what do you call the thing that keeps
the shoelace together
that little input the end bit the toggle
that if you separate that into like 24
pieces
that's what we're looking at that when
you get down to that
smallness it doesn't behave like the
bigness does it no
nothing makes sense up is down down is
up and then you've got these really
weird things like
the way that they behave it's like isn't
it something like
happy smile joy excitable going to a
party
not too sure about life something like
that right it's bizarre quantum physics
but it is something like that
the way that they just you've just
described it perfectly
and nothing exists unless you look at it
right
nothing weird isn't it because when when
they've
when an experiment has occurred when
there's an
observer it behaves differently but
what's really confusing about that is
when they say this was an unobserved
experiment well then at what point
would did you know what had happened
because you've got to watch it at some
point and that's when it changes
and then a wave becomes uh
like oh and a hello becomes like a how
are you doing
exactly right you're like a scientist
right right
i know some stuff about don't you so you
would want to do an intensive
would you not think after two weeks your
mind would just go one of the experts on
the subject and i read his book and i
forget his name
it might it sounded like quark maybe but
he said anyone who tells you that they
understand
theory does not understand string theory
because it's you can't understand it
exactly you're like my string theory
right
impossible to get your head around why
is it called string theories the strings
involved
they're basically saying that everything
is made up
of vibrating strings and depending on
how fast they vibrate
that's what they are and you had told me
this thing years ago that
brian cox who is the the chief lecturer
of science at manchester university it
said whereby
if a particle on pluto
shifts every single particle in the
universe
also has to shift if it's if it's an
electron
at a certain distance from the proton
if it goes into someone else's place
they all have to shift and go oh
something so with you waving your hand
like that you've moved some electrons
around haven't you
yeah and see when you moved your hand
like that you did that
every possible way that you can shake a
hand
until i observed it and then it became
that way
are you still with us listeners ladies
and gentlemen we have lost you on the
friendship onion so
i think we should try and find a way for
you
well you know what we we actually are
members of the great courses
plus website in which they teach
string theory and quantum physics why
don't you do a crash course
and then we'll talk about it a bit more
and you can fill in the gaps
can we have an expert on the friendship
onion
who would talk about quantum theory
to us because he could tell us that
thing of like
it the way they move it's like up down
happy
smile not too sure about stuff it's
similar to that honestly yeah
okay my one would be if you could learn
the subject from the top expert in the
field
mine would be are we doing two week
course is that what you said no i just
made that bet up
oh well i would take it from the
question from elena
i learn a new skill from the world's top
expert
i would learn jujitsu from the best
jujitsu artist i went to brazil for
my tv show while things were looking for
the green anaconda which we found
it bit me on my inside thigh and you
would have put in a neck hold if you'd
known
jujitsu the guy taught me the anaconda
a few days before you know the anaconda
it's like um
it's like an omaplata you know hello
that's not an italian side dish
it's like an oma platter it's a choke
hold but you
twist like a snake you twist the guy
over with you as you go
and i think from my recollection let me
know if i'm getting this wrong
listeners or viewers i think you trap
the arm but the guy taught me and it was
extraordinary he just said
go limp and i'll show you what to do
and within a couple of seconds i was
like tapping out oh
yummy gummy and then he said okay do it
to me and the brilliant thing about
jiu-jitsu is
it doesn't matter how much bigger or
smaller the other guy is if your
technique is better you will beat them
more
it's it's not about using your body
strength so he just said yep just turn
me around
okay now apply pressure and he tapped
out i think you should learn i think you
should actually go and i think you would
like that
i think i'd love it i think you'd be
good at it as well it'd be good there'd
be
classes in los angeles right there would
be classes with the best here wouldn't
they oh didn't you what's the family
the um the gracies you should learn from
the greatest there's actually one
close to me uh near my street in los
feliz there's a there's a
gracie jiu-jitsu look how we've just
worked that out i'll go have a look
go do it today there's another question
go on bills
this is from chris from waltham's store
oh where east
17 were from east london of course
now he says hey billy and dom just a
quick question
if our legs bent the other way
what would chairs look like that's a
good question actually
it's a great question isn't it so our
legs bend
so apparently so this is knees i think
we'll talk about
i think we'll say it's knees so our legs
bend like what animal
do well stocks are a good example do
they go down
inverted and you know kids are not born
with kneecaps
it's true can we have a fact check there
can we have a fight get it out there
babies are not born with kneecaps
they grow over i think 18 months or so
i'm gonna i'm gonna try before we get
the facts here
i'm gonna say that babies are born with
kneecaps that are in three pieces
oh they're not fused and then they'll
fuse together into a kneecap
let's see let's hang on here comes our
john here you go
the answer is yes and
no babies are born with pieces of
cartilage that will eventually become
the bony
kneecap or patella
which adults have like bone cartilage
gives structure where it's needed in the
body the reason they don't have kneecaps
at birth
is because it'd be very difficult and
risk
injury during the birthing process oh
the bending
break stuff well done well i think we
were part right
i said they weren't born in kneecaps
which is probably true but then you say
well they're born with
pieces of their kneecap that come
together
i think that was very good but anyway
anyway we're talking about the chest
yeah
so a chair is not a good way to sit
anyway
it's bad for your back what even this
yeah any chair
what's a good way to sit well what you
want to do
is you want to squat you see no i'll
show you
well be careful unique because he has
knees of an 80 year old man
see that is that the way this is the way
you should be sitting for anyone just
listening
i've pets myself on my chair without my
legs hanging over
yeah because you shouldn't sit with your
legs hanging over like that
that way of sitting is extremely popular
in southeast asia and the continent of
africa
where you will very seldom see someone
with a bad back
yeah that's true how are your knees by
the way because your knees were terrible
hey i'm still seeing a man about it can
i also make a
recommendation for you because this is
very common and it's gonna sound silly
you have if you don't mind me saying a
massive wallet
what a massive wallet thank you it's
huge
i know supposedly sitting
with a big wallet in your back pocket
will throw off your knees i want you to
google search that
it throws off you hit it because your
pelvis your knee
it causes terrible problems i've taken
my wallet out and i've placed it over
here
but do you often sit on your wall
sometimes actually
and also my man what i'm seeing from my
knee he says stop
crossing your legs so much the michael
corleone and the godfather
chairs are not good but anyway what
would chairs look like i think if her
knees went
that way so oh i'm thinking they go
yeah no you're right sorry if you're
only listening to this guys
so if your knees went the other way then
they wouldn't go towards the floor that
way
they go towards the ceiling so i think
there would be an extra part on a chair
you know like the you know like the the
uh weight thing in a gym
where you push the weight away yeah i
love that one well see that
yeah there'd be a thing like that right
so when you bent your legs
and your your heels went towards the
ceiling you would then
crank the thing in that would then hold
your legs towards the ceiling yeah and
that would be part of the chair
hey tom you ever get those days when you
feel about anxious yeah sometimes i do
do you know what i do then i get cbd
from feels
oh yeah feels is a premium cbd that will
help you feel
better keep your head clear and you know
just have you have a nice day
it's hassle-free and delivered directly
to your door and the cbd
is completely natural helps reduce
stress
anxiety if you've got any pains aches
and pains your back or whatever
great for neck and back pain brilliant
and if you can't get to sleep
very good for that there's also no
hangover and it's not addictive and
in fact feels offers a free cbd helpline
to help you guide you through your
personal experience
so that you can find your perfect dose
the fields customer service team is
dedicated to making sure you get the
best use of your cbd
fields are great for that they give you
a little dropper and you just
you know you can see how much you
actually want to take stick it under
your tongue
brilliant so start feeling better with
feels become a member today by going to
feels.com
onion and you'll get 50 off your first
order with free shipping
that's f e a l s dot com slash onion to
become a member and get 50
automatically taken off your first order
and free shipping
50 off your first order with free
shipping you gotta do it
we've got another question here from liv
in sheffield
where my one of my favorite english
bands of all time come from pulp
pulp very good jarvis cocker amazing saw
them a few times and liz
from sheffield in the united kingdom
asked one of my favorite genres of films
are b
movies campy horror science fiction
comedies and thus
love your work billy on space milkshake
and dom on i sell the dead they're
amongst my favorites
would you mind talking about them and
maybe some
other campy b movies that you both like
p.s when i described those films as
campy b movies i mean it in the most
respectful and
endearing way well very good
i like a campy b movie
because it's you know
independent cinema at its finest really
i think
there has been a squeezing out of
people's ability to make
lower budget films and it's easier to
make
lower budget films when the agreement
with the audience is
look the special effects aren't going to
be ridiculously brilliant
it's not going to be all polished and
fantastic but the script's going to be
good
the performances are going to be 100
committed and that's what we're into
for a long time and eve and still now
i've obviously been very keen
on supporting independent cinema
and this film i sell the dead uh
approached me when i was doing this i
think the second
season of lost and we didn't get around
to doing it until the
third season of lost um
and it was great great cast ron perlman
um
east side of new york mainly night
shoots which you would have hated it was
freezing
yeah um but yeah tons of fun you you we
should always be supporting
our independent filmmakers because
ultimately they're going to be
going to be the people that are going to
come up and be the establishment at some
point so you should know them when
they're uh
younger yeah as yeah i totally agree and
also
that just that passion you get with you
know what
liv uh calls b movies um
just that passion of like with space
milkshake the writer was so passionate
about making it
and and all the the special effects were
physical special effects so the guys
like the wetter guys that
we all met you know they're so
passionate about making these monsters
or the
you know the weapons and how it's all
going to work it just gets you so
excited about making those movies you
know
and and that you can you know
change things and and have fun in the
moment without
too much of a worry there's a producer
somewhere in
l.a who's going what what why are they
doing that why is that funny
yeah you know you're inventing it and
you're all in it together i love that
yeah i like that too let's quickly while
we're here just very quickly touch upon
uh league of legends and where we're at
with elijah playing league of legends
with us
on a scale of fruit from
let's say the seeds of a strawberry
being terrible and a watermelon
being the top where are we at with
elijah playing league of legends with us
i would say we're
at i mean a very small
sour grape yeah like a grape that's
starting to turn into a raisin but it's
not quite there
we shouldn't really eat it yet it's not
quite sweet enough last thing he said to
me which i thought was very
disconcerting i said
download league of legends live we're
gonna play it this weekend and he wrote
back
ha ha i'll download it now that wasn't
ha ha that you're funny i'll download it
that was more like
yeah nervous laugh i will download it
but not right now
what do you think it is why do you think
he doesn't want to play with us
i think he's busy right you know you had
a son that was almost two yeah and you
probably didn't have that much time to
play video games
i also think even though he spent a good
couple of hours with us that day and had
a great time
i think secretly in his dark dark heart
he wants us dead
both of us yeah wow so he doesn't want
to play a game with us whilst plotting
our
device you know what i mean he would
rather be fully transparent and say i'm
going to back away and then i can
plan you guys as double murder so fair
enough
fair enough for ledger keep it going and
then just very finely on the league of
legends thing we did have quite a bad
goal of it didn't we well i didn't play
no the last time we played that was the
last time i played as well
no you played this i mean you played a
four-game session with
with nine nigel well that was a
four-game loss that is awful but before
that
didn't we have a three-game loss is that
right it was quite
and by the end we weren't really not not
talking
i just mean i just mean in a way that
we're just like right
should we stop yeah shall we surrender
no it's going to be my last game let's
not certainly
you were approached by a professional
gamer who said i'll play with you and
give you tips right someday did send
something on uh twitter so i will get
back to them because i need to know how
to get better i don't know how to get
better well my fear
you said to me should we do it and i
said yeah let's do it but i said my fear
is
that this person is just going to end up
shouting at us for 40 minutes
because we don't really know what we're
doing we need somebody with the patience
of a saint
yeah as a professional gamer i think
he's going to be like now what are you
guys doing that's
you shouldn't you should know by now not
to do that
do you know what i mean so it might not
be that enjoyable but i'm into it let's
do it i'm going to be in top
okay hey is it time for voicemails
it's voicemail time let's hear voices of
humans
hi guys my name is izzy and i'm just
wondering what was the strangest moment
of your life
that doesn't involve lord of the rings
the strangest moment of your life well
for my uh life at the mo
the first thing that comes to mind is
when i met prince
i don't get uh william or
harry no the prince prince prince
the purple one the man formerly known as
the man formerly known as prince
the symbol right so uh i was lucky
enough to get invited to a house that he
was playing a concert and
for very few people and uh
and i met him and he was such a part of
me growing up
that meeting him was like the most
surreal
weirdest i've met lucky enough to meet a
lot of people
yeah famous or whatever yeah but meeting
prince was
that was surreal tiny tiny but yeah was
he wearing heels
yeah he was so how big was he there he
was smaller than you still
still small i was wearing heels
we were both wearing heels which
canceled out the heels
but he was he was lovely and he looked
at you in a lovely way
quite a deep voice right that was always
the surprising thing about hearing
prince interviews he had quite a deep
voice because his falsetto was
extraordinary
yeah and because he was such an
otherworldly sort of
presence on stage i didn't really
think of him as a human being until i
met him really
and then it was just wonderful he just
like us normal guys
how are you and wow did he sing he did
he sang for about
four hours he did two sets what what
were the more iconic
songs that he said everything did he
sing purple rain yep
you swine i love that song
yeah i didn't i wasn't invited to that
that was you and all he wasn't he should
have been invaded
yeah i think you were out of time i
think i was out of town actually
but yeah i remember you telling me and i
was like what you went to was it is his
house or just a prime minister i think
it was a house he was staying in
los angeles but it wasn't his house it
was just a house
of a friend or something amazing
what about you what's the weirdest thing
yeah a lot of weird things happened a
lot of weird things happened to me but
um
i think the weirdest thing i mean
there's a lot of
there's a lot of weird stuff
um i have a
i'm very profound at times
connection to animals and
sometimes that kind of connection
can really lock in and
become something that is really hard to
explain like
like i feed my wild lizards in my front
garden so there's
the very common lizards that you'll see
around your garden as well
are called mexican fence lizards fast
skittish little things
not in any way harmful the the insects
and stuff
every so often i'll buy 20 or 30
crickets throw them out there let the
lizards do their thing
it creates more crickets a more healthy
garden there's more lizards
out there and stuff like that the first
few times that i did it the first couple
of weeks that i did it
as soon as i opened the door the lizards
would scatter and i would
throw out the crickets and then i'd have
to go sit on my sofa and stay very still
because with reptiles if you stay still
they generally can't see you
and the lizards would come out and eat
but then
what i started to do was stay in that
place
so i would stand there throw the
crickets out and let the lizards realize
that i wasn't going to move so they had
to you know come closer to get their
food
and then get lower and sick and come
outside and all this kind of stuff
then you get to a point where because
you'll see these little lizards that
when they're looking at you their head
tends to tends to
move sideways when they try to look at
you the same way that birds do and
there was a point a few weeks ago where
there's like 10 or 15 crickets jumping
around
in front of him and i'm sat on the floor
and then i readjusted and there's like
three lizards and all three lids at the
same time just went
and just looked right at me as if to say
we see you we see you moving
and i just without without speaking just
try to kind of stay calm so that they
felt that calmness because these wild
animals will only really
connect to an energetic thing they
obviously don't know what you
what you're saying what you're doing and
very quickly they just kind of went
okay that's fine it doesn't seem to be
doing anything too hectic
and went back and ate and those kind of
connections to a very
wild and and uh different animal
as our own happens a lot with me it's
not as weird as it used to be but i
think for a lot of people out there they
think oh that's
kind of strange because people say to me
all the time well do your animals do you
pet your animals do you take them out
of their homes and stuff like that i
said no they're all
wild and they said well what what do you
get out of it but
the connection to a wild animal
that you're not that you're not asking
for anything back
you're just you're just there giving it
food can be extremely
profound and also you'll see things that
you would
that you would never see in the world
you know you don't see
rattlesnakes yawn in the wild
so to to be an observer of that is an
amazing
privilege you know yeah yeah nice
thanks thanks for your question hello
there
marcus from argentina i have a really
important question that's like
one of the most important questions
somebody might ever ask to you
and the question is if soap falls into
the floor
does the floor get clean or the soap
dirty
it's a very important question that is
an important question coming all the way
from argentina
i love these type of questions right
well i would yeah
i would say
both in a quantum way
i think both is a good answer isn't it
because yeah there's a piece of the soap
that is connected to the floor
that'll clean the floor but that part of
the soap has been compromised by
that'll get dirty off the floor
sometimes i'll take the very end
bit of a bar of soap right because my
the tiles on my shower floor are not
completely flat they're kind of grouted
okay
and i'll rub the soap all into those
gaps
and i'll just leave it there so then
over the course of the next few showers
it'll start to
melt away and clean the floor that's my
hope
well i think you're saying that it will
clean the floor
yeah that's why i do it and when you do
this
is this after us are you still naked i'm
always naked in the shower
is the water off by this time yeah the
water no no the water's on
what's on do you ever sit in a shower
never i do i like that
what did you see i liked sitting in the
shower oh sit sit oh yeah
i had i had dengue fever once oh
horrible
oh it's horrible uh administered by
not on purpose but by a uh mosquito who
has the parasite inside its body
flew back from peru was in my shower i
don't know what my
temp my fever was but it was a high it
was 108
it could have been i felt terrible
splitting headache
painkillers wouldn't work sweating in my
bed it was like a have you ever had that
where you oh your bed's like a paddling
pad
you like roll over and it's like
so i thought i'll get up and have a
shower
but i was so weak i was like a little
kitten i had to sit down
in the shower i was crying in the shower
because i felt so weak
but then after that i brightened up
because i thought
oh this is latin quite nice actually
just sitting there just being rained on
because i don't have a bath as you know
and you're a massive fan of baths
but is that when you thought to yourself
i'll get the end of the soap here
yeah and i'll just get stuck into the
grout i love
a little like i love cleaning my kitchen
surfaces i love spraying all the kitchen
spray bottle into the corners and
leaving it yeah for like 20 minutes and
then coming back and getting it really
clean
but i took out my bath that was a
terrible idea
which i didn't really think through
because then someone came to me and said
well
then when you sell your house you're
gonna have to advertise it as
three bedrooms two showers and people
are gonna say where's your bath and
you're gonna show up
tore it out i love a bastard yeah you do
don't you yeah
i don't understand the bath because i
get in
yeah as soon as i get in the part of my
body that's in the water
is significantly hotter than my head and
my hair
which now starts to sweat and get hot so
then i think okay
submerge yourself under the water give
yourself a nice refreshing kind of
bathing of your face and head
so i do that but then my head starts to
itch
my face starts to sweat people say just
read a book but my book gets wet people
say have a glass of wine
i don't know where to put it light
candles that's a fire hazard
bring music in you're going to wreck
your electrical equipment
you on the other hand have got that all
diamonds i have got it dialed in
can you read in a bath no okay you won't
do that other than
i may have a look at my phone oh my god
oh yes oh you drop it that's it no
they're waterproof now
well really but for soap and you know
some of that sputum
no that's all right the only thing that
will happen is if you go to charge it
your phone will say
i'd detect some water don't charge me
just now
put them in a batteries stick me in a
bag of rice
basmati basmati is the best for them but
because
sometimes when i when i call you yeah of
an evening
you'll say i'll get back to you in half
an hour i'm in the bath so for you a
bath is half an hour
45 minutes a bath to me
would be about the length of an album
yeah so just under an hour yeah i will
listen to but not always a whole album
quite near the king career so it's a big
favorite in the bath
uh i remember in new zealand annie
defranco was
massive annie defranco's still there
really yeah she's
she's on she's on the bathroom pink by
annie defranco i love her
so um is it kind of a meditative thing
you're like for this next 45 minutes
there's no dog there's no wife there's
no child it's just me
yeah and i like candles i'm not ashamed
to say that
right i like candles i light a little
bit of incense
and i just lie there dom and i just let
the world
spin right we have a shower afterwards
nope
but you're covered in your own filth
you're
you're soaking wet surface
level filth scum i'm gonna call it
because that's ultimately what it is
you immerse yourself in and when you
come out it
sticks to all your extremities and then
you just simply towel yourself
off well that basically takes us back to
the the question
does the soap clean me or do i dirty the
soap
if anyone has any real scientific
evidence about
do you get dirty
in your own bath water or does the bath
is the bath water self-cleaning
it can't be because i mean sometimes and
if if anyone wants to do any art
uh friendship onion art of dom sitting
in a shower crying with dengue fever
crying with dengue fever
but coming up with the idea of using the
end of the soap just to clean the
grouting
yeah i do like that also sometimes
and i don't i don't know where this
comes from right sometimes i'll find
or i used to find hairs in my bath
that were not mine not mine
but i know what my hair looks like end
your bath yeah
does it come through the plug hole no i
don't think so back up the other way i
don't think so oh there's another myth
for you since i'm such a fan of
such a fan of uh creepy crawlies and
arachnids obviously
lots of people think spiders climb up
through your plug hole
and they can go back down through your
plug hole not
true spiders do not climb up through the
plug hole
they're simply searching around and they
accidentally fall into a bathtub
that they can't climb out now here's a
great tip for you guys this will save
you
and save the spider if you're scared of
a spider and you've got one in your bath
and you don't want to get rid of it
simply take a bath towel put it down
into the surface of the bath
and make sure that the bath towel then
goes up and over the other side onto the
floor
outside the bath leave it overnight the
next morning spider won't be there
because spiders are smart and they will
escape but they do not live in your
plug-o so if you wash
a spider down the plughole you've killed
it you don't want to be killing spiders
they're amazing creatures
a scottish person will never kill a
spider is it
do you know why it's something to do
with robbie burns robert the bruce
robert the brutish robert in a cave tell
us the story
he didn't know how to how to go on how
are we going to get scotland back to its
own nation
and he was about to give up and he saw a
spider making a spider's web
and he'd make some of it and then it
would break and he went back
and make a little bit of a spider web
and it would break again
and he watched this little spider do it
10 times
and he said if if first you don't
succeed try try again
and robert the bruce went back out and
defeated
the english and scotland became its own
nation again
i don't know if that's slightly shorten
the story but you know the spiders
brilliant have you seen those
experiments with spiders where they give
them a little
coffee or they give them a little yeah
other
kind of stimulant yeah see how they do
the lsd one's fantastic
just makes like a bunch of pyramids and
shapes yeah sits in the corner thinking
about string theory
okay oh we've also had some reviews
should we read out these reviews oh yeah
how does this work again tom could you
explain it we've
we've panned down a little bit pan down
here we go
we've been asking you wonderful humans
to
not only rate the uh
friendship onion podcast but also uh
reviewers and if we love the review
we'll put it up
on our social media pages some of the
other days said something like
such a simple review it was like
something like just like eating a lovely
bar of chocolate
well isn't that nice isn't that great so
here's a couple of standout reviews but
go on bills
i was just going to say because i have
read some people say where do you leave
reviews
and it's not easy to find so i looked
yesterday
on the sort of apple side of it and you
have to go to the home page
of the friendship onion you go down to
the the reviews
and then it says would you like to leave
a review yeah and then if you do
leave a review take a screenshot of it
tag us and and send us it before you
press enter
on the review because then it disappears
brilliant
here's a review from ah mulliga
who said not to make you feel old but
this show delivers a really wonderful
sense of nostalgia
really takes me back to a time when i
was young having fun doing skits at my
local public access station with my
friends
your friendships made our friendships
feel more magical i can't say why
perhaps it's silly
anyway the podcast takes me back even
though those old friends are gone for
the most part
one passed away last year sorry to hear
that others i just lost touch with
also sorry to hear that i can feel that
feeling we shared together again
and it feels good oh well that's lovely
ah malaga
maybe the ones that you've lost touch
with you could get back in touch
it just happens sometimes with
friendships things drift away and then
they come back at a more appropriate
time let's hope they come back
yeah here's another one from nka
to there have been a couple of podcasts
that have piqued my interest and kept my
attention
this is absolutely one of them these two
have undeniable chemistry
and knowing that it came from my
favorite films of all time makes it even
better
i love their personal stories just as
much as the stories about the time
on lauder rings we hang that down
loved it it's nice isn't it it's nice
it's nice to get positive feedback from
you guys and guys
we we've been asked by the whole team
over here
to keep looking through these reviews to
make sure we we can find ones that we
like
so we do read them and we do love
hearing from you guys so make sure you
review it
give us a little five star rating the
more five star ratings we get the more
reviews we get the more we can make the
show
the more we make the show the more we
can actually start to understand
string theory and life in general so
stay
take a screenshot of your review tag us
on our
instagrams at the friendship onion and
we'll read them out here or we'll stick
them on the instagram
philly and dom eat the world it's my
favorite part of the show what is it
it's billion doll eating the world
well here we are this particular dish
was suggested to us from asro what a
beautiful name
azra from half moon bay in california
have you ever been to half moon bay it's
a lovely sounding place
it does sound fantastic where is it well
they only ever get partial light
yeah which is terrible where is it i
don't know i've never been
i'd like to be able to have this uh lady
or gentleman i don't know is that a
lady's name or a jedi i'm gonna
guess a lady okay i'd like to be able to
say
my friend azra who lives up in half moon
bay
that sounds like a nice thing maybe
maybe you could send us a postcard from
half moon bay yeah yeah let us know
where it is
i'm gonna guess that ezra with a
beautiful name like that
might be from iran or have iranian
parents because what we're eating today
and i'm probably going to get this wrong
so bear with me
is koresh carafes
not bad doubt not bad do you want to
give it a go
oh
don't you see the itch after the key
good point
chorus very good otherwise known
in the english language as celery stew
but i'm going to pull them up on it
immediately because there's actually
meat in here so you can't call it a
celery stew
if the main ingredient is meat we don't
tend to eat meat do we build no we don't
and uh
you see the thing is dumb i had i hadn't
eaten any meat other than fish
which is a meat from the seed as a meat
and i don't really know why i made that
distinction but about 15 years ago i
stopped eating meat
and uh but i still eat a fish uh but
over this covered time somehow
slightly sometimes now i'll have a piece
of meat
like if something's been cooked in the
house i still would never order it in a
restaurant or that but if someone's made
something
iu or a friend's house
and uh i would normally say oh no it's
okay
i don't eat meat now i would maybe take
a little bit
and i would eat that that's great it's
like it's just listening to what your
body needs right
yeah maybe it needs a little bit of me
maybe or
maybe just i don't know i don't know
either but from an evolutionary point of
view
we are opportunistic omnivores we're not
carnivores that only eat meat
such as lions and snakes and we're not
herbivores that only
that don't eat any meat at all such as
well let's say a cow for instance
well done or a horse but we from an
evolutionary point of view will eat
whatever is opportunity
opportunistically in front of us
and sometimes that is meat and i know
that will open a can of worms
i wouldn't eat worms on the internet but
we're just being honest about
who we are and what we do yeah we're
just good to be honest now we're going
to try this
celery stew here i actually hit it
against my nose there we smelt it
because i tell you something about
celery tom and you won't like this
because you're a big
veg lover i love celery i'm not a huge
fan of celery
well i wouldn't necessarily describe
myself as a fan of celery
for me it's more of a medicinal thing
but what i will tell you about celery
which is fantastic
it's brilliant for people with problems
problems with the sinuses
oh really it has a kind of uh
an effect on the sinuses of reducing
volume of sputum
is that the not the best goal not the
best thing to talk about before you have
your first plate of clearash
crafts let's give it a go here we go i'm
going to get a better salary
yeah me too
now what i was going to say about celery
there was actually
i love watching somebody with a stick of
celery and some ranch dressing
yeah i think i'll look as if i would
love that but you don't
no but if you cook celery
then i quite like it like this my mother
and father
austin and maureen who you know who say
hello
they love a braised celery oh so just
kind of
almost poaching in in something else's
juices
they like that is that what'd you call
this porsche
possibly hold on not sure now it's not
spicy
you and i both love spicy i was
expecting or hoping for a little bit of
spice there it does have some
turmeric in it which is a fantastic
anti-inflammatory spice
i try and get as much turmeric and
cayenne pepper into my system as
possible
to the extent where sometimes on the way
out
you're aware of maybe a little bit more
capsicum than normal
but it's worth it i tell you what tom
it's got good flavor though it's a good
stew it's a good flavor
it's like it's like an irish stew like
my grandfather
who invented gasoline as we have
discussed
but irish stew in the name of the law
exactly
but it does have that saffron turmeric
which gives it the the persian not a
bait
but a persian flavor hold on there's
definitely a lot of flavor to it
um saffron
one of the most expensive
it's not a spice mm-hmm it's a part of a
flower i believe it's the stamen
of a flower how's it really i believe so
much
one of the most expensive things in the
world saffron yeah
if you get a good saffron it's weight um
that's delicious that dumb gum
it's absolutely delicious i i've been
eating it with a little bit of
pita bread over here in the united
states
people refer to people from iran as
being persian which is correct
since that is kind of the older ancient
name for it but in
in britain we would just simply say that
those people were from
iran in fact my friend ryan
whose father sadly passed away quite a
few years ago now
was from persia and his name was hormoz
and when he came over to the united
states his friends at work said
now that's not going to work for us that
we're going to call you john
huh and for the rest of his life he was
john and
not our producer john no no he's not
ryan's dad as far as i know
you're not are you john no he's not he's
shaking his head now let's find out some
other stuff
like most jews the longer you let this
celery stew
simmer on a low flame the more flavorful
it will be
this is also a great make ahead of time
dish now that's the other thing i was
going to say
this would be great like if you're
watching your kids play football or
something
you bring out some little dishes of this
it's fine hot or cold
a little bit of bread on the side that's
absolutely delicious tom
and you know that is a
it's a intense flavor but as you see
it's not um it's not overly spicy but
there is another bowl here
that i don't think i'm going to get into
don because as i say
i don't really eat meat at you but this
this um this a celery stew over here
well i'll tell you what's in this one
because the one we had there is
basically the celery
maybe with a little bit of beef but hold
on i'll tell you this tom
can't get my my glasses on lamb's head
jesus tongue oh my god
feet what green pepper onion garlic
saffron turmeric cinnamon salt
pepper the other stuff is fine but as
hobbits i don't think we should be
eating
feet do you i think hobbits would would
they think they would
make their feet a little bigger maybe
well yeah that's probably why they
their feet you know it was just
evolutionary from eating feet
their feet get bigger have you eaten
tongue before uh as a boy
so and my dad used to eat pig's feet
he would sit in front of the tv with a
pig's foot
and he'd destroy that thing over the
course of an hour
all of our fathers tend to have horrific
stories about meat don't they grown up
like my dad used to say
that his mum would bring home a sheep's
head
and that would be food for the weekend
so that would be you know the
cheeks would be the friday night type
thing and then as the
as the kind of weekend went on they'd be
eating
poorer elements of the sheep's head
maybe an eyeball
i can see why that would be right though
like if if an animal has to die
then you should use all of it absolutely
you know not just take the
the breast off you know i mean
but yeah it kind of puts me off what
about awful
yeah you should you should use all of it
as i say
but you know it's it's not it's it's not
for me for me it's not a great thing not
really a fan of off although i will say
and sorry to anyone who doesn't
eat me and as billy said billy and i
have gone through periods in our life
where we do eat meat we don't eat meat
we try and be as responsible
as we can be but i remember being in
france one time
in a restaurant and they love me in
france don't they yeah
and nearly any part of it and i had
poached eggs on i think it was an
english muffin from i remember
with chicken livers and it was superb
superb but i honored the chicken you
know
i honored it well this is a thing thank
you for your service chicken friend the
thing is
i mean it's a big subject and not one
that we should probably go into right
now
is a big subject and we're sorry if
anyone's upset over there anyway
we'll finish off with a couple of things
here about koreshkara the word
koresh or khoresht
is a generic term for stew dishes so
that just means stew so carafes
oh i was going to say carafes must mean
celery but that might not be right
well it may be if koresh means stew then
maybe carafes is celery crushed crust
is a healthy flavor flavorful food made
with
meat celery mint parsley kidney beans
and pomegranate paste
it's not a dry stew though and it
shouldn't be runny like soup
i used to have a chef friend and he said
that if you're making a soup
and it gets too thick you just say it's
a stew
and then you still keep it on the menu
love that
now we've got to give it scores out of
ten haven't we yeah just a couple more
bites of the celery element
oh yeah let's get into the gravy i think
that's where the good stuff is
it's quite healthy this stuff i say that
about life don't they so
the categories are number one
flavor i'm going to give this a massive
big bite and then
you give us your flavours because i
think that's lovely there's a few things
i think for both of us and i'm talking
for you here dom i
do if it had a little bit of space in
there
it would be up there as a 9.5 but
without the space
but with a quite intense saffron
i'm going to give this an 8.2 it's still
hard oh yeah can i say this might be
controversial for people
listening because we're mixing different
cultures here but i'm gonna guess that
you might
love this i would like to add some of
that
giardina stuff i mean why don't we start
mixing things
which is which is from mexico is that
right
no no john is from boston chicago yeah
but it's not originally from chicago
it's from italy italy but they used to
add
oil and then in chicago they started to
add a vinegar to make a pickle now a
little bit of that on the side
you would lose your marbles it would be
up there as a 9.8
as far as i can imagine or did you give
it an 8.2 8.2 for taste
for me now i'm sorry i love iranian food
and i've had some fantastic iranian food
it's not my favorite i like food with a
bit of punch
so i'm gonna demote this to a 7.1
well that's all right don that's okay
that's all right now next we get on to
aesthetics how does it look to you if
you had to look at it
with your eyes what would you say well i
mean if i'm looking at it with my eyes
um right it's
not the most attractive looking thing
you know the colors are not
gray green you know that it's
all right i'm gonna i'm gonna give it a
seven
i'm with you dom it's it's a little
i don't like that the shade of green is
not a great green
no it's not like a salad green it's more
like a slime green yes a bit
and so i'm going to actually take it
down yes 6.8
you've been quite harsh this week on the
lips
yeah absolutely next how useful
is it in your lifetime this is when i
think it come really comes into play oh
here we go
well because i'm going to say you can
have this cold
you can take this on a trip with you if
you're going to watch you your
friend play football or you're seeing
your son in it
or your daughter in a game or maybe
you're having a little picnic with your
pals
or maybe you've gone camping you've got
some hot stuff but you want to bring
some cool stuff with it i think this all
works
so i'm going to say in terms of
usefulness
i'm going to give it a 9. i think that's
good and as you see
you can have a big pot of this on maybe
there's a vegetarian version of it there
must be there must be
a big pot of that and a big pot of the
other you invite friends around
just enjoy it you might say and then it
gets better day after day
so i mean dom it's a 9.1
oh you've trumped me okay great i don't
know what our ultimate scores are but
someone
someone back there will tell us and
we'll just finish off this
the final thing about the stew here
because this is really interesting there
are many restaurants in various cities
in iran where customers go
and eat kele patch
every morning its popularity is under
threat however from the spread
of fast food and from medical doctors
warning about the dish high cholesterol
some people drink a cup of strong tea
after eating it to neutralize
the detrimental effects of high
cholesterol i'm not sure if
you know like eating a pizza or a burger
yeah
and then having a glass of grapefruit
juice after it yeah cancels it out
no although i've heard apple juice is
very good if you're going to eat a pizza
or something like that
but i think sometimes people
forget about the traditional foods
because they'll take one thing about it
you know because this has got
the the calipash here as you said has
sheep's heads
trotters like my dad would eat in front
of tv
and i don't think this stuff is bad
because it's natural isn't it so natural
it's natural so i think we should go
more down the traditional route than
going for the more processed food and
thinking we're eating healthier somehow
i don't think we are i totally agree
well good that was another fantastic
element
uh episode i should say of billy and
don't meet the world please send in your
suggestions that was a fantastic
suggestion
food or beverage it might be tasty or
slightly peculiar
we will stick it in our gubs well that's
it
again another week in the books we'll be
back next week with more stuff
so make sure you get in touch with us
but before we go a little surprise for
you
hope it's a gift i wrote you a a song
i'd love to hear it
it's not quite finished yet but it's
nearly it's a work in progress
but i want you to hear it so that maybe
when we come around next week
you might have made some notes on it we
need to get our songs together
and get them on here i'm seeing you this
sunday so maybe we can put everything
yeah but i wrote this little song as i
say it's not quite finished let me know
your thoughts what's a title
it's called billy i love it already good
stuff ready here we go
hilly it's not quite finished yet
it's it's like an idea that's
forming in real time you want to hear it
again yeah
billy i think it's like a lament
it's almost as if maybe you've gone away
i've not seen you for a while
there's a lot of potential there oh
there's definitely potential in fact
that is probably in the world of song
that is a quantum song wow you mean it's
like
all potential is there no i mean it's
tiny oh yeah it is it's absolutely tiny
now before we go don't forget to rate
review subscribe if you leave a review
screenshot it tag us in it
send it to us we'll repost it on
instagram or we'll read it out right
here
get in touch with us on our social media
pages you can also email us
the friendship onion at castmedia.com
that's cass with a kicking k
that's right you can send us a voice
message www
dot forward slash no no i've done it
wrong again
guys we'll get there eventually you can
leave us a voice message
on www dot what is the thing
speak pipe dot com forward slash
the friendship onion you nailed it
killed it
um yeah guys we'll see you next week see
you next week
toodles